à
[Applaudissements]
suprême de christine jutard main dans la
main si la réalisatrice
est ce trop beau pour la première fois
en sélection c'est la galère
plusieurs films toi moi et les yeux pour
moi les autres histoires balle à la
tolar avec sophie marceau
elle présente pétition en séance de
minuit suprême
[Musique]
toute l'équipe
les regarde réunis
[Applaudissements]
une ambiance de folie
a démarré avec le dj cut killer qui mixe
en haut des marches comme il le fait
régulièrement à cannes et qui signe la
bande son la bande originale du film
deux jeunes acteurs formidables pour
incarner
joeystarr et kool shen théo christine
on n'allait plus
car ses cheveux
il ya peu de temps le film fait partie
de la belle 2020 canon
[Musique]
sandor funtek
il est présent français en demi nue avec
suprême est également en compétition
avec l'histoire de ma famille dit qu
elle lui dit il avait un petit rôle dans
10 pts de jacques audiard qui avait reçu
la famille
en 2015
et une autre palme d'or à son actif de
rien l'ami d'un réel d'abdellatif
kechiche palme d'or
et l'actrice en 2013
c'est au bénin
et je vais
on l'avait vraiment remarqué dans un
premier rôle d'un trait d'un feu joseph
bauer qui était sorti l'année dernière
si je me souviens bien cas contraire de
saint barth
et puis on l'a vu récemment dans les
trains
ludovic bergerie
vous avez aimé
mal de films déjà à l'actif de cet
acteur d'augmenter un nom à coucher
vous voyez hein
cop killer milliards en france on va
très prochainement
sont du restart
l'union fait la force
suprême ntm est dans la place
on
[Applaudissements]
nico
que tu l'aurais joey starr
cette killer de raconter tout à l'heure
que l'aventuré a démarré au milieu des
années 80
concurrencé amitié mêlée
[Musique]
si vous nous rejoignez sur l'antenne de
télé festival c'est la montée des
marches
suprême d'autres
hugo
et il ya le niveau sur tapis rouge
ils sont déchaînés
[Applaudissements]
autant vous dire que c'est le bonheur
pour les photographes
au christine
se détachent du lot habillé tout en
blanc quand les autres sont en noir
séance de minuit sont loin protocolaire
que les séances de 19 heures
une ambiance plus libres qui sied bien à
l'univers une liberté de ton affaire
avec joey starr qui mène au bal du prêt
c'est toute l'équipe du film qui va être
accueilli
du festival pierre lescure et par le
délégué général thierry frémaux
les
g
mais un tel qu'une ambiance pareille
pour maintenir éveillé
spectacle sur les membres regarder
[Musique]
oh
à
nommé chiche en fait j'ose à peine leur
jeu
ainsi le produit
suprême d'audrey estrougo ce qu'en soit
le 24 novembre
il est présenté en séance de minuit
cette soixante quatorzième édition du
festival de cannes
chorion ça qui fait là
si vous voulez vivre libre les débuts du
groupe ntm
si c'était français de la fin des années
80 et du début des années 90 l'impact
qu'ils ont une société sur le débat
politique
je conseille vivement d'aller voir ce
film
alors deux
avec en vedette on les avait vus sandor
funtek était au christine dans les rôles
de russian et joey starr
[Musique]
hors du coup
n'est ce pas
j'ai envie de rester